on a une économie qui est en train ah
c'est cool et qui est dans un des
moments les plus difficiles de ces 10
dernières années une hyper inflation on
a ceux qui souffrent aujourd'hui de
cette crise de cette absence d'essence
c'est qui c'est pas le grand patronat
c'est pas les bourgeois qui ont
souffrent c'est le petit travail
ailleurs c'est ceux que vous avez été
rencontré il y a quelques minutes à la
station essence sont les infirmières
libérales qui peuvent pas aller faire
les piqûres au patients dans les
campagnes c'est les parents qui vont
conduire leurs gamins à l'école qui
peuvent pas aller emmener la petite
faire son cours de danse nous sommes
extrêmement favorables à la réquisition
de tous les dépôts de l'ensemble des
raffineries pour refaire en sorte qu'il
y ait de l'essence du guysol qui puisse
être mis à disposition des
automobilistes qu'on retrouve une
activité